revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 Rosa Pérez mateu y tenemos una
revista de prensa muy especial Porque se
cumplen 100 años de transmisión de la
bbc Y empezamos en 1922 cuando arrancó
esta cadena Rosa Exactamente no Y empezó
siendo una radio recordemos es la
broadcasting que es la compañía de
radiodifusión radio televisión ahora
británica pública no Y empezamos con
algunas anécdotas de los inicios de la
corporación británica de medios
audiovisuales públicos Y es que por
ejemplo en 1926 el país estuvo nueve
días en huelga muchos periódicos dejaron
de imprimirse dejaron de publicarse y el
gobierno del entonces
stylight quiso poner la mano sobre la
bbc y tomar el control pero por ejemplo
su primer director general John Race no
cedió porque dijo que la imparcialidad
de la bbc por ejemplo se vería para
siempre Y esta es una de sus banderas
todavía hoy en día por ejemplo más tarde
en 1933 Sheila borrett fue la primera
locutora mujer en ser contratada por la
bbc Raúl pero solo estuvo tres meses en
antena porque hubo muchos oyentes que se
quejaron de que les molestaba oír a una
mujer en la radio o por ejemplo en 1900
a 38 contrataron al locutor egipcio
ajmal que fue el primer locutor en
lengua árabe Y es que recordemos también
en tiempos del imperio británico la
bebecieron gran instrumento de control
colonial y ya vamos a un momento muy
clave de la historia así es 1940 el
discurso del que fue presidente francés
tan importante este discurso Rosa bien
este discurso ha pasado a la historia
quizás de una forma más magnánime de lo
que fue luego ha sido bastante
controvertido No un poco la puesta en
escena de ese momento lo que sabía
todavía de gol y su complicidad o no con
el Alemania nazi pero en todo caso el 18
de junio de 1940 de Gol pronunció en
Londres una discurso en el que se erigió
como líder de la resistencia francesa
Porque recordemos en ese momento ya
estaba pues bajo ocupación nazi y ya
estaba en ese momento al mando en
Francia El general petán y precisamente
No pues Winston Churchill reconoció a
the Golf como líder no de la Francia que
resistía a la ocupación nazi durante la
Segunda Guerra Mundial y escuchemos este
un breve momento de ese discurso que
como decíamos ya ha pasado a formar una
página de la historia
yo general de golf invito a todos los
franceses que quieran permanecer libres
a escucharme y a seguirme viva Francia
vamos cuatro años después cuando la bbc
retransmitió el desembarco en
normandía en 1944 Rosa Exactamente no
una de las operaciones que ya fueron
poniendo fin digamos a la Segunda Guerra
Mundial una operación clave no de esa
guerra una operación de los ejércitos
aliados escuchemos hemos seleccionado
solo un fragmento pero lo que me ha
llamado mucho la atención de la forma de
leer es el comunicados que precisamente
leen un comunicado pero Enseguida lo
repiten como pasó un poco con la muerte
de Isabel la de segunda no en que el
presentador dice nos acaba de llegar
este comunicado lo lee y acto Seguido lo
vuelve a repetir En todo caso escuchemos
esto es Londres London llamando a casa
al exterior y a través de los servicios
europeos de la bbc y a través de la
radio mediterráneo soy John snack
hablando
porque les generales de los aliados han
expedido el siguiente comunicado número
uno y en unos segundos se lo leeré
comunicado número 1 bajo El comando del
General Eisenhower las fuerzas navales
aliadas apoyadas por fuerzas aéreas
empezaron a desembarcar ejércitos
aliados esta mañana en las costas del
norte de Francia
y como hablar de la bbc rosa sin por
supuesto hablar de la Reina Isabel
segunda 1953 la coronación efectivamente
no Y eso es algo que comentamos cuando
se murió que precisamente fue la primera
vez que se retransmitió para el pueblo
la coronación no y fueron 20 millones de
personas las que siguieron ese acto como
bien decías en 1953 y avancemos un poco
en la historia vamos a 1964 la música
por supuesto tan deliciosa en los años
60 Exactamente no y es que la bbc ha
sido escenario de muchos a grupos que
también han pasado a formar parte de la
historia de la música veamos nada un
fragmento de un grupo que enseguida
vamos a reconocer
[Música]
Claro que sí los Beatles y en 1969
llegamos a la luna efectivamente Y
retransmitida en directa esta frase no
de un pequeño paso para el hombre una
gran salto para la humanidad escuchemos
La No le hemos puesto voz encima porque
hemos creído que era más interesante
escuchar el sonido original
en el 69 llegamos a la luna pero en el
97 llegaron los Teletubbies Exactamente
no muchas cosas pasaron en estas décadas
pero nos hemos querido centrar un
momento en estos personajes que han sido
icónicos seguramente para la infancia de
millones de niños alrededor del mundo en
todo caso la mía y la mía de hecho Una
curiosidad y es que hubo preocupación
entre digamos los pedagogos porque los
Teletubbies no pronunciaban palabras
reales sino sonidos que hacían
referencia a los primeros sonidos que
pronuncian digamos los niños pequeños
pero en todo caso Bueno más o menos bien
Hemos salido no estamos hablando aquí
con palabras completas
veamos un fragmento pero que ya es de la
nueva generación de Teletubbies
[Música]
llegamos a los 2000 rosas exactamente Y
es que una forma que tuvo muy curiosa la
bbs de empezar el nuevo Milenio fue con
el reportero John Simpson en la isla de
Kiribati en el Pacífico Sur porque de
hecho fue el primer lugar del mundo
donde se entró en la década de los 2000
Raúl Entonces vamos a ver a continuación
nada este momento para recordar no como
fue este cambio de Milenio seguido de
cómo fue en Londres Ya pues este paso al
año
se siente muy bien estar aquí debajo de
las Estrellas y escuchando este tipo de
cosas bueno se siente muy bien
francamente sea como sea desde aquí les
decíamos feliz nuevo milenio
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y aquí estamos 22 años después Rosa
Muchísimas gracias como siempre por esta
excelente revista de prensa pasamos a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado del
día